cyberpunk 2077 was one of the most
anticipated games of the last 10
years but it was completely broken as
[ __ ]
at launch since then two class action
lawsuits have been filed against the
developer
accusing them of straight up lying to
investors and knowingly launching a game
that was literally unplayable for a lot
of people on console
[Music]
alright so here's where i tell you to
scroll down and hit that subscribe
button so
you know go ahead and do that while
you're at it hit that notification bell
so you
never miss a new video the launch of
cyberpunk 2077 was among the worst we've
ever seen
especially given the hype no other game
in recent memory
has gone from potential game of
generation to
flaming disaster quite like it has
and because of their awful launch
developer cd projekt red
is now facing two class-action lawsuits
which accuse them of lying to investors
about the broken state of the game
as well as blaming them for all of the
problems that happened post
launch you guys also might remember that
the game was so
broken at launch that sony microsoft and
best buy not only offered refunds on the
game
sony [ __ ] pulled it from the entirety
of its digital store
on top of that we recently got the first
of two gigantic patches
intended to and when i say this i'm only
being slightly hyperbolic
fixed the entire game and when you know
it players are reporting
a new game-breaking bug because of these
patches
alright so let's start from the
beginning cyberpunk 2077 was announced
in 2012
and it was confirmed that cd projekt red
would be developing it the entire gaming
world spent the next
eight years losing their [ __ ] minds
every piece of concept art every trailer
every chunk of gameplay
drooled over by eager fans wanting to
get their hands on this thing and to a
certain extent you can't blame them
this was the follow-up to the witcher 3
widely considered one of the best games
ever made
and at that time cd projekt red could do
no wrong hell in 2019 they even pledged
to get rid of crunch
you know that kind of forced overtime
that's just unfortunately a fact of life
and video game development
it's something that they were known for
in the past and it's something that they
wanted to fix
unfortunately the entirety of that cdpr
can do no wrong
sentiment disappeared in 2020. by then
cyberpunk 2077 was in late stage
development in anticipation was through
the roof
but from january up until its eventual
release in december
that anticipation was met with growing
concern
here's just some of the stuff that led
people to believe that cyberpunk
might not be the perfect game we were
hoping for for one thing
there was three separate delays and then
there was the revelation that forced
overtime hours would be necessary when
they publicly said it wouldn't be
and finally there was the overly
sexualized marketing that feels like it
came from the mind of a horny eighth
grader
there's plenty more but we don't have
all day now for most of you watching you
know what
crunch or being forced to work a ton of
overtime hours
is and i don't think you'll be surprised
when i describe it as honestly a
terrible
and inhumane practice i worked about
seven days a week
between 14 and 16 hour days and when
would you go home
i would go home when i was ready to
collapse basically and we're not talking
about working overtime for a week or two
at a time here
according to a report from bloomberg
published in september not only were
mandatory six day work weeks being
enforced
some developers on staff have been
working extra overtime for more than a
year
and well it turns out that those growing
concerns were justified
because when cyberpunk launched on
december 10th
it was an unmitigated disaster
especially on console
like just look at some of this [ __ ]
you're certified bug free bug free
[ __ ] victor not bad i don't know what to
say
say you'll take this and remember the
dosage two whips now
and another two in an hour and while
those clips
are hilarious it's like how could you
think this game was
ever ready for launch looking at this
stuff and on top of all that
the game was literally unplayable for
some people and when i say some people
again we're talking about enough people
for sony microsoft and even goddamn best
buy
to start offering refunds on the game
and the fact that sony pulled the game
from its digital storefront
now that is unheard of now in the
immediate aftermath of the launch
cdpr's stock plummeted 29
we're talking about 1.8 billion dollars
wiped out and it's here where we loop
all the way back around to those two
class action lawsuits that i mentioned
off the top
essentially both lawsuits accuse cdpr of
lying to investors
and the general public about the broken
state of the game prior to its launch
and due to those alleged lies a broken
game was sold to the public
that cost investors a ton of money and
these lawsuits are basically trying to
recoup
a piece of that money for its investors
as well as getting cdpr to
pay legal fees here's two examples of
statements that the lawsuit alleges were
either lies
or full of bias and just for context
these statements were made by cdpr
management to investors during different
conference calls
quote i wouldn't say that there's a
problem because there's nothing wrong
with the xbox or ps4 versions
there is optimization to be handled also
because of how we were approaching
things from the get-go in terms of
development
so there is no problem with xbox or
playstation 4 to be honest
end quote the lawsuits then cite another
call after the release of the game once
it was
abundantly clear that cyberpunk was not
ready for launch
and here's what cdpr management had to
say then quote
after three delays we as the management
board were too
focused on releasing the game we
underestimated the scale and complexity
of the issues
we ignored the signals about the need
for additional time to refine
the game on base last gen consoles it
was the wrong approach and against our
business philosophy
on top of that during the campaign we
showed the game mostly on pcs
end quote from there the lawsuit alleges
that by
making these false or misleading
statements cdpr
violated various sections of the
exchange act
and the exchange act basically
encompasses all of the rules laws and
regulations around buying and selling
stocks in the united states
quote because of their positions of
control and authority as senior officers
the individual defendants were able to
and did
control the contents of the various
reports press releases and public
filings which the company disseminated
in the marketplace
during the class period throughout the
class period the individual defendants
exercised their power and authority
to cause the company to engage in the
wrongful acts complained of herein
end quote what the lawsuit is saying
here is that senior management at cdpr
had control and final say over messaging
and marketing around the game
and either lied misrepresented or
straight up just
didn't tell anybody that the game was
busted and remember because cdpr
management allegedly lied about the
state of the game investors lost
1.8 billion dollars you'd expect people
to be
pretty heated and then finally the
lawsuits ask that cdpr pay for damages
and
court fees and then demand a jury trial
and while both
these lawsuits read as too gigantic this
you
twitter threads it'll be interesting to
see what impact
if any these court cases have on the
games industry as a whole
and as if that wasn't enough cdpr are
breaking their game in new ways
while trying to fix it they recently
announced
two gigantic patches they hoped would
fix everything
but instead it just introduced a new
game-breaking bug
essentially what's happening is that
dialogue that's supposed to trigger
and move a quest forward doesn't happen
and then you're stuck this was enough of
a reoccurring problem that on january
23rd
cdpr put out a statement basically
saying hey here's a workaround
just load in a different safe which is
truly what you don't want to see
so really it turns out that cyberpunk
2077 is not the boundary pushing
revolutionary video game people wanted
or thought it was going to be
it's a pretty ordinary even fun game
with a ton of ordinary and industry
specific
problems that have been around for
decades at this point
and honestly that's all it was ever
going to be
i'm trying man all right
i'm trying
i can't we're in the middle of a
lockdown
i know i know there is and the funny
thing about all this
i look like an insane person because
nobody can hear what you're saying to me
i'm not like i'm not grumpy at any at
you or in any person
well we have our m board
that hurt my hand